let's give ourselves some practice
adding mixed numbers so let's say i want
to add two let me write it this way
let's say i want to add two and four
sevenths
plus
three and two sevenths three and two
sevenths i encourage you to pause this
video and try to think about what this
is going to be
well there's a couple of ways that you
could tackle it one way you could say
well let me just add the non-fraction
parts you could say that 2
plus 3
is equal to 5
and then you could say
that 4 7
plus 2 7
is equal to well 4 7 plus 2 7 is going
to be equal to 6 7. anyway wait how did
i how did i do that how did i just you
know just only add the fraction parts or
add the whole parts but the way i did
that is because 2 and 4 7 is the same
thing
as 2
plus
4 7 2 and 4 7 same thing as the 2 plus 4
and then plus
3 and 2 7 is the same thing as 3 plus
2 7. so all i did over here 2 and 4 7
plus 3 and 2 7 is 2 plus 4 7 plus 3 plus
2 7 and you can swap the order in
and how this happens so you could take
you could just switch the order and say
this is going to be 2
plus 3
2 plus 3
plus 4 7
plus 2 7
plus
2 7
and what we just figured out was that
2 plus 3 is equal to 5 right over here
and that 4 7 plus 2 7 is equal to
is equal to
6 7
just like that
now let's do a more interesting example
let's do
let's say that i have
three
and
three and three-fifths
plus
five and four
five and four-fifths
now what is this going to be equal to
well if you do the same technique
if you add the three plus the five
you're going to get eight
and then if you add
the three-fifths
plus four-fifths
you would get seven-fifths so you get
eight and seven-fifths
and this wouldn't be wrong this is eight
and seven-fifths if you add these two
things together but it's a little bit
strange here because seven-fifths is
bigger than a whole so to get a better
sense of what number is really being
represented here i want to rewrite this
so eight and seven fifths this is the
same thing as eight
plus instead of seven fifths we could
say this is the same thing as five
fifths which is a whole
plus two-fifths
plus two-fifths now why is that
interesting
because five-fifths notice five-fifths
plus two-fifths that's seven-fifths
right over there or you can consider
five-fifths to be one so this is eight
plus one which is nine and two-fifths
nine
and two-fifths so all i did here i added
it the same way that i did the first
problem a few seconds ago when i
realized that this fraction part is
greater than one i separate it into one
and then a fraction that is less than
one and that that whole i was able to
add to the eight to get to nine and then
i would have two-fifths left over eight
and seven-fifths because five-fifths as
a whole is the same thing as nine and
two-fifths so if i wanted to write this
in kind of a i guess a clearer way i
would say this is nine and two-fifths
three and three-fifths plus five and
four-fifths is nine and two-fifths and
once again i'm sorry three plus five is
only eight how did i get a nine well
that's because three-fifths plus
four-fifths is greater than one